all let's see here we haven't heard from
him for so long
Steven I think we're connected but I
can't hear him I don't know if he can
hear me
hmm I think we're connected right now
he can hear me okay we can't hear him
that's interesting let's see what we've
got four settings here settings voice
and video input device output oh I see
hold on input device Steven can you hear
me
I sure can we can hear you now Wow
beautiful beautiful beautiful wait can
you hear me yeah we can
Oh your microphone changes well oh
what's up yeah I wanted to give you my
silky microphone so I changed the
configuration thank god the other one
was very coarse yeah I figured that you
were gonna be displeased with it so what
what's going on I feel like I haven't
talked to you since since the brunch and
oh Jesus
things have gotten crazy since then not
well like I my issue I just want to talk
about real politics and online is like
so white and so left and so socialist
it's so boring that like all these
politically irrelevant dip ships
dominate like the YouTube and twitch
fear oh my god you're shot out of a
cannon I don't even know what you're
talking about um in like my corner of
the internet it feels like the majority
of the discourse is about like [ __ ]
socialism like the riots over this the
black like the black people dying to the
white police officers is actually about
like the Bernie Revolution and [ __ ] and
it's like oh my god so I've just been
like I'm trying to just like Auto mute
and auto block everybody now on Twitter
it has to do with like anybody that
calls themselves the [ __ ] socialist
or communist or large does any of these
like far-left ideally I'm just muting
them and trying to get back to like
tweeting like more relevant ideology so
things that like Tim Poole are saying or
steven crowder or ben shapiro or any of
these types I'm just trying to
desperately claw my way out of this like
vacuum of irrelevant political thought
wait a second you're trying to get into
the things that Tim Poole and Ben
Shapiro were trying to get into talking
about those issues again like I'm more
interested in talking about like what
Trump is doing right now rather than
dealing with these delusional dumb you
can I love swearing your channel
yeah we're just on Twitter right now
yeah okay yeah rather than talking to
the delusional dumb [ __ ] that are
convinced that like Joe Biden is just as
bad as Donald Trump so like these like
the Michael Brooks of the world of the
Kyle kolinsky of the world oh my god
like I'm trying to get away from like
that delusional stupid [ __ ] and back
into like more mainstream political
conversation it's so much more
entertaining to me than arguing with
another person that is another
interpretation of some socialist [ __ ]
ideology it's so boring thing I hate it
and these are like the loudest people in
my corner of the internet so it's really
frustrating for me to do it so I go is
this Steven yeah what's up what is good
I I'm shell-shocked by what's going on I
feel like I saw you three months ago and
wit I just don't even understand what's
happening right now yeah well um how's
your life been I mean I haven't been you
know going down the tim pool ben shapiro
rabbit hole I guess I would say geez
remember well I'm sorry when I say that
when I say like going down that road
what I mean is it like the issues like
talking about like Trump and how he's
like demonstrable harmed the United
States and yes issues are more relevant
politically than like how can we become
a socialist control oh my god I don't
listen yeah I'm not a socialist and I
agree with that but you're you're not
like but ben shapiro is not doing that
is he yeah be we'll wait hold on i'm
sorry you might you may be
misunderstanding what i'm saying yeah
what I'm saying is that like ben shapiro
or like tim pool or joe rogan these guys
are putting forth arguments that I think
are harmful and relevant to current
American oh oh yeah so I want to be in
the realm of like I want to respond to
like what the Crowder's of the world are
saying or what the Joe Rogan's are
platforming or like I want to respond to
that type of harmful thought not argue
with socialists and communists all day
so let me see if I can like put the best
positive possible spin on this what
you're saying is we've got five months
to an election that is either going to
be Trump getting reelected or Joe Biden
and so for you theoretical arguments
about socialism are less relevant than
exposing Trump's totalitarian tendencies
and
on November 3rd yeah 100% that's a way
more relevant argument yeah I see I see
yeah or like if I'm talking about
between like Biden versus Trump the
argument shouldn't be who's more likely
to usher in a new era of worker owned
capital or socialist revolution it's
like well who's gonna be less harmful
for the United States or more beneficial
towards like our progressive values our
immigration system
maybe universal health care stuff like
that is more what I'm interested in do
you think now I mean listen I'm a Social
Democrat so that's like well regulated
capitalism my audience knows that you
know maybe your I guess knows that ok
fine but what do you think of the
argument a caller just made this to me
10 minutes ago that we need those
socialists to move the Overton Window
sure I guess yeah no I the problem is
that a lot of these online socialists
don't understand at all how political
systems work and when real life people
do try to move the system for the left a
lot of these guys online turn turned
against him anyway a really good example
of this as of lately has been like AOC
or the justice dams or Bernie Sanders
notice how they are making real changes
towards the platforms of Joe Biden and
trying to move the country to the left
but now all the Socialists of like
disavowed these types of people and are
like oh well [ __ ] you Bernie you're a
sellout or [ __ ] you aoc like you know
you sold out too hard to Pelosi you were
way better when you and your campaign
head
we're like firing off like dramatic
tweets and other like Democrats all day
long like that's actually the way for it
so III think that like and to be clear I
need to enunciate this every time okay
I'm only talking about like the online
radical very very extreme what people
like the real life progresses and Bernie
fans and justice dem fans everything I
think these guys are largely cool so
like the the chank chank chank yogurt
types i don't know how to prank you go
yeah you yeah like those types I'm okay
with like those guys are cool I
appreciate the work they do and I do
think that like having somebody like up
like a Bernie Sanders type to push us a
little bit farther to the left I think
is good yeah there have been like
changes in Biden's platform you know
they've come together and they worked on
making certain concessions to win over
Bernie's writings I think that's largely
like a good thing and I would credit
Bernie and his pretty far left run in
accomplishing some of that yeah I agree
I mean I I found it I was concerned when
aoc and Bernie beau
said things that to me seemed sort of
like uncontroversial after Bernie
dropped out and yeah after the fact some
of their supporters were like they've
either sold out or they were never real
they were always playing a character or
something like that like what does that
say about the people who followed them
so closely like were you so bamboozled
that you did like you you now all of a
sudden after you know following Bernie
for years you're like oh he could now he
sold out like are you such a poor judge
of character that you didn't notice all
along yeah the problem with a lot of
these people is honest to god like a lot
of it is just people just don't really
know how the United States political
system works like it really comes down
to just that dude if I had a dollar for
every time some far-left [ __ ] says
why didn't Obama fix the police like the
[ __ ] is the president gonna do he does
he's not the guy that puts in like
police commissioner's everywhere he
doesn't dictate a local police policy
for not to mention the fact that even if
he could Obama only had the ability to
pass meaningful legislation for two
years you understand the president can't
do this unilaterally yeah they don't a
lot of people just have no [ __ ] idea
the second part of what you're saying I
agree with but there's no question that
I mean listen Trump when Trump's it says
I'm gonna open up the economy because I
shut it down it's like no you didn't
shut it down it was governors who
decided to shut it down and ultimately
it's governors who are going to decide
to reopen it but there's no doubt that
if Donald Trump earlier had said hey
governors I need you to be with me on
this it would have had an impact and in
the same way I don't think it's
unreasonable to think that a president
could do the same when it comes to
police reform if they wanted for it for
two years yes but not when not when
you've lost your majorities in a certain
Senate like at that point yeah well
listen I mean for two years even without
the the Senate or the house a lot of the
stuff depends on States the president
could still say hey governor's here's
what I want to do who's with me sort of
thing you don't need but the problem is
like if you if you lose so much in the
midterms in like these I don't know
these are historic landslide losses are
well but and they were massive losses
yeah like how much political capital
does Obama have right like Obama can
like listen you know you guys if you
need to be with me on this and they're
like okay well listen dude like you're
not winning us any elections at the
moment like yeah I don't know how much I
don't know
not like Trump whereas before the last
midterms I would argue that Trump seemed
to have quite a bit of political capital
but he could kind of move people around
although he sucked at it so maybe not
even but like at this point I don't
think Trump has as much political
capital to get big things done either
right because you know we saw a pretty
big blue landslide in the house you know
coming up to the presidency holy [ __ ] we
might even see like a flip of the Senate
yeah just like the electoral politics
game is like is a pretty nuanced game
that has to be played at you know at
state levels that people just don't care
about a lot of times people think the
president is literally a dictator that
can come in and just single-handedly
unilaterally get all this stuff done and
he just can't it's not that powerful
yeah that's that's um definitely just a
you know misunderstanding about how
these systems work but you mentioned a
little bit before that in in your screed
about the people you're furious with you
mentioned Hasan and I don't I don't want
to tread carefully because my instinct
is that there there may be something I
don't know I don't know what's going on
but well were you upset with what he
ordered when we went to dinner where you
were like how could I know how could he
choose those dishes and was that this
like I feel like I might have been
responsible towards the next time I see
you okay I'm on ironically in a video
game okay oh I'm sorry my mic yeah like
you seem to be very much against lamb
and he ordered lamb and no but seriously
like it's like atheist thing like I
think lambs are peer and you know III
out like you you guys are this is not
like a fake beef now no I don't fake
beefs all of my [ __ ] is real that I do
online like I don't have like these like
hey we should pretend to fight with each
other blah blah blah like I wear
everything on my sleeve like all my
positions are it all my friendships are
real like yeah I don't you know I don't
set stuff up for drama online or
whatever and is it if I may it's his
political positions that have infuriated
you or was there a falling out of
personal nature well so like in the
beginning he misrepresented himself as
being like a liberal but the reality is
it he's a socialist and he like is
sanely like anti-liberal right so like
he so him and a whole bunch of other
people on then he was like liberal is
like an insult now they call him Lib
tardes and they say oh liberals bla bla
bla and I'm just like I said I'm trying
to get away from talking about like the
socialist [ __ ] like it's just so boring
to me I'm so politically irrelevant but
now couldn't like I guess I'm trying to
understand
because I'm one of the things I'm trying
to do is as long as people aren't
hateful like if somebody hates Jews I
mean I do not have a tough time getting
past that and just kind of hanging out
but I have friends who are socialists
and I'm not a socialist and you know I
don't feel the need to always talk about
that we can talk about other things I
don't see it as like a personal affront
is it it would did something happen
where it boiled over oh so I'm I'm
capable of being friends people that
have vastly different political beliefs
than I but like I'm gonna call them out
on it and a lot of people get really
upset if I argue with them about their
beliefs so like our big falling out was
he did a video on Kamala Harris where he
pretended to know anything but he was
just regurgitating Twitter headlines and
we had a discussion about it he lost his
[ __ ] mind so like that was like the
big falling out and then like later
things came up where you know I was
having discussions on different types of
social issues than he would you know
appear into these podcasts should argue
with me and then we would have a big
argument and I need hate me or whatever
and then basically that's see that makes
me sad yeah well I mean that's yeah I
mean I agree but it is what it is in
other words you're you it sounds like
you're saying you would rather that it
had gone a different way
yeah of course I mean like I like having
friends of like different backgrounds
yeah I mean I think it's cool like
people but it's really really hard
especially with people that are a soft
as a son like to have people that are
friends with you that have like wildly
differing beliefs that are like willing
to challenge you on it like typically
people like that preferred to not be
challenged dramatically on their beliefs
they just want to have like you know
chill times see I mean I don't know I
guess that's not been my experience
personally with Hasan but admittedly
I've only you know done a couple of
things with him where he seems open to
being challenged as long as I guess I
mean in the same way that I'm open to it
if it's respectful I don't know but I
guess it's just that you know you're
obviously you're totally respect that
that's how you experienced it yeah I
mean that's I mean it is what it is yeah
what do you know what do we think we can
do to rekindle this cuz I would love to
go back to dinner with you guys next
time if we I remember I'm ever traveling
again um well you're gonna have to it'll
be like shared custody I guess one of us
will get you and then the other one of
us will get you I think that that's the
Rica's that's like when when there's a
breakup when you're friends with a cop
and there's like everybody has to pick
sides you know you don't have to listen
you can visit him first I won't hold it
against Jerry well no it's not about
first it's just you know why can't we
all get along and unite against Trump
um I mean that's not what he's concerned
with I guess hmm that that's dude I'm
bummed out I'm honestly I'm like I'm
bummed out by this mm-hmm well yeah I
mean I was too but here we are
how are things going from the standpoint
of just streaming and twitch like are
you I know during coronavirus a lot of
people are just streaming even more than
they normally do yeah I think so I've
been streaming quite a few hours yeah I
mean it's I mean I guess like I always
feel like quite a bit so life hasn't
changed that much for me thank you and
did things I I just haven't been
following this there was a point at
which you were discussing almost like
getting a streamer house together yeah
there was a deal on the table for a big
house in Beverly Hills but the contract
just wasn't right and they wouldn't
budge on a couple of like pretty
important provisions so I ended I'm not
going through with it was one of the
provisions the exotic animals stuff yeah
basically like like me and Lam I just
can't live in a household where that
stuff is served even on like I got them
down to a bi-weekly basis on it because
we're gonna do every Friday night and I
tried to move them towards like at least
monthly because I could leave the house
once a month and we'd be okay but the
most they would do is bi-weekly and I
can't yet it has twice a month that's
also a violation of my atheistic beliefs
and I have to stream at least 28 days of
the month so yeah that was basically
where we got stuck at is in all
seriousness though how often are you
leaving the house are you wearing a mask
like what how are you what you know what
is your coronavirus routine I mean you
know if I if I go to the store or fast
food places or whatever yeah I always
wear a mask right now yeah interesting
and are you like will you are you the
type of guy that goes for a run
sometimes and you wear a mask when
running no no I would never wear masks
and running I don't think if you're
outside I don't think it matters as much
yeah I just saw a contact tracing study
which says 0.3 percent of contagion
happens outdoors
and of that it's got to be
overwhelmingly when people are doing
obviously dumb stuff like crowding big
crowd at a hiking trail or something
like that but real quick I just want to
give a big shout out really quick in
case I missed him Demiurge shadow and
your chat not 100% of the time somebody
tells you that the reason why you don't
understand something so you don't read
as much that person literally is
illiterate they actually can't read and
the reason why they're telling you to
read is they assume that it's like super
beneficial but they don't actually know
because they can't read this guy
probably can't even type he's using like
a speech to text program on his computer
that automatically input speech reader
there's a guy in your chat who is
illiterate and I'm actually
congratulating him that he's capable of
actually chatting like as often as he is
without actually being able to read so
big thumbs up to that guy okay I'm sorry
you're talking about being outside oh my
god masks in the crowd go ahead you're
like wound up in some way me oh wow you
really think so
I don't I mean you you you you seem
almost like you're you're on speed
you're debating my chat no I'm not I
just want to give a shout out to it you
had a cool dude and chef even he needed
attention I could tell he does and what
he didn't get it growing up and now he
can get it from me now I'm Demi air
shadow Demiurge shadow he is big mad he
says oh my god all right I mean things I
feel like coronavirus is getting too a
lot of us in different ways yeah
unfortunately not to the right people
sometimes in a video game yeah no it
definitely is there's like a a lot of
[ __ ] going on yeah are you doing any
travel at all I think that international
travel is banned right now so I don't
think I can do that I've thought about
like there's locally but I don't know I
don't want to get I don't know about
insurance I'm kind of paranoid going to
the airport and I can just stream
because everyone else is so you don't
have you don't have medical insurance um
not at the moment now how did you is
that by choice I'm guessing well I'm
choosing not to pay 250 a month for it
if that's what you mean yeah yeah at the
moment yeah that's interesting and how
that mean is it is it just like you've
made the mathematical call that you just
doesn't doesn't make sense to pay it
yeah well from a strictly math point of
view it doesn't make sense to pay for it
but from like a risk assessment point of
view I probably should be I'm just lazy
yeah I hold a car you 31 chil damn yeah
like [ __ ] double bypass 90% blocked
arteries or some [ __ ] type 1 type 2
diabetic
going on over here to a relatively
healthy guy 250 sounds cheap to be
perfectly frank I pay for 30 in
Massachusetts well we're not all YouTube
superstars that are making millions of
dollars a month
okay pumping out 20 videos a day David
no button up but but I think that's sort
of the point where to me not having it
exposes you you you have to be in a
stronger financial position to not have
it because you're at risk of a huge bill
which I'm yeah that's what you're
talking about yeah what you're talking
about is um it has to do the risk
management basically that the the
downside is is very low to buying
insurance because I'm not gonna miss 250
bucks a month but the upside is
tremendous because I avoided a
potentially catastrophic financial event
I thought exactly yeah yeah that's and
it seems to me like now you'd be you you
would resist going to the doctor unless
it was like an emergency right because
you don't want to get dinged no I go to
the doctor I just pay out of pocket oh
you do okay what does that even cost uh
why usually if I go to the hospital you
just feel like STD testing so I don't
know I have that oh I got immunizations
a while ago I guess that was like turner
bucks yeah you you would get the the
corona virus vaccine right uh well I get
an antibody test for it's probably right
to find out if I've had it and then if I
haven't had it then maybe I'd get a
vaccine I don't know is it
maybe I should I'm not sure I'd have to
think about that I don't usually get
like flu shots because I don't really go
out much you don't go out huh that's
interesting and would would the vaccine
being from any particular country
dissuade you from getting it oh I don't
yeah I don't know if I trust vaccines
from Israel really okay that's what it
was gonna be the first one I was gonna
ask ya cuz you know what you know I'm
pretty white and ya know I don't
actually don't know yeah well you know
it's a crazy world out there David I see
for me I would be in I would be
reassured by the vaccine being from
Israel really yeah you you you would be
wouldn't you yes I would David I hope
it's from Israel really you know they
manufacture it first I'm um listen my
real concern is that with all of trumps
posturing about getting it just for the
US
that someone else will get it and they
just won't give it to us and we'll be
the ones who are screwed
but you think yes crab would give it to
us I think Israel would give it to us I
think you know after the BS with Germany
I don't know that we're the first place
Germany sending vaccines to true that's
true modern I guess I'd probably help if
anybody manufactured I probably hoped
that the United States manufactures it
well listen man I I am worried about you
I'm finding something about this call a
little unnerving if I'm totally Frank
what's unnerving about I don't know I
have you there's an there's an energy
from you that is is I don't know I don't
know there's something going you into or
are readings now is that way we you
gonna do some Ricky on me well I don't
believe Reiki is a thing but I know that
it's very very lucrative for some people
okay have you been doing lately how's
your broadcast human gone the
broadcasting is fine I've got I mean
listen I'm in the same situation as
everybody I don't really do anything and
it seems now I mean it's like okay in
Massachusetts yesterday outdoor dining
started is outdoor dining safe I guess
it's reasonably safe but is it necessary
I don't know what do you mean necessary
like am I am I gonna be so much better
off emotionally if I go to sit outside a
restaurant with whatever additional risk
it brings I just don't know I feel like
it's just really unclear now what you
know how to even evaluate like okay I
like going to restaurants but do I
really need to do it right now I don't
know it just so very weird in between
time yeah I imagine for some people just
getting out probably feels good yeah I
mean listen I'm going out I'm running
I'm biking sometimes I'll have you know
I'll have a couple friends over and we
stand outside 30 feet away and and talk
I've shown and stuff like that exactly
as long as you're doing like the the
bare minimum until I kind of keep
yourself and your lacasa
safe have you heard of shunga shun guy
shun kite shun got Suge Knight shun guy
no with that I'm just like a rock
protects your house it's oh yeah yeah
you put it put it around your house
keeps you safe from the 5g you hurt
you've heard about those things right
you know the other day someone walked by
my house with a with a mask that said 5g
caused this and he did my Nate I don't
think so my neighbor asked them that's a
joke right and the guy said yes but like
it wasn't convincing if that makes sense
huh yeah okay I don't know interesting I
what have you got any fashionable or
special masks like you have any David
Pakman masks no no David Pakman as a
viewer did send me a reversible mask and
I don't know I'm thinking now everybody
everybody now has these black ones that
are very very stylish and they're almost
like sport cut or something and I don't
even know where people are getting them
mmm
what kind of mask are you rocking all
right I just ordered a pack of 10 like
standard cloth stretchy nylon I don't
know what they are whatever masks like
the Mertens of medical ones no those
those actually I find those a little
unnerving I don't like those at all
makes you feel like you're on like a
post-apocalyptic zombie movie or it
reminds me of when I had appendicitis a
few months ago and everybody around me
was wearing those it's just it's not I
don't need I don't want that when I'm at
the grocery store if that makes sense
true I think it'd be cool if everybody's
wearing like Bane masks rim The Dark
Knight Rises maybe so listen while I
have you what should I be doing on
Twitch I'm trying to keep growing and
revitalizing on Twitch and I just don't
really you know I I'm thinking of what I
want the right twitch strategy and you
seem to be a good person to go to for
that well right now
holy [ __ ] David right now the twitch
meta is actually chess did that's right
actually yeah it's a nano Hikaru has
like 400,000 subscribers all of a sudden
followers I'm sorry yeah that was
callers phone yeah yeah we used that
word is different around here yeah I
forgot about like where you come from
yes so I should I be should I be
revitalizing the chest stuff you might
be able to yeah there's a lot of
grandmasters that are playing on Twitch
now that's interesting getting like
10,000 plus beer so when I ran a
tournament a couple months ago the
tournament on Lee chest got 500 players
obviously the stream had more but
five hundred players maybe I should run
another tournament would you play in it
if I did maybe I consider it you know
you would consider it yeah I would I
think I would I think next week is going
to be chess on twitch for me and we're
gonna see how it all goes in fact I'm
gonna pick a time right now I'm gonna
say Tuesday night is the next David
Pakman show chess tournament 8 p.m.
Eastern Tuesday night and you're invited
Stephen do you okay a p.m. Tuesday night
est est oh my god that's 5 PS tea for me
on a Tuesday let me yeah but I got one
my schedule see what you got going on
yeah you know what you know I've got
something scheduler 5 o'clock
David Pakman chess there you are there
we go and we're gonna get Hassan in -
you better tell him I'm gonna be there
good no I think we're do it Tuesday
night at 8 p.m. I think it'll be good I
do want to get back to the chess and
it's great to catch up with you I I'm
not kidding that I'm a little just
worried you you had at the start of our
call you had a bit of like a manic
energy but I do feel like we're doing
better now yeah most of the time I'm
pretty level I just you know my my
bipolar kicks in the started
conversations talking to you you're like
internet famous
oh is that a little bit yeah I get like
a little bit nervous when I as soon as
you pick up I'm like oh god it's like
David Pakman I just want to like go off
like a million miles per hour for all
the different political opinions and
everything I've had and all the stuff
I've been doing it's really [ __ ]
nervous you know he's do is that because
of an insecurity of some kind I don't
know I I think I just I radiate you
mentioned like the aura show that you
heard earlier I I just I radiate a lot
of yaqoob' and energy and when I talk to
you it just just sets me off in a way
you know a little bit yeah after we chat
for a little bit I think I I chill out I
cradle my shunga
my three million year old Shanghai rock
and everything just feels a little bit
better so do you do bonsai um I used to
own bonsai kittens the ones that fit in
the jars but not know I don't do bonsai
what's that know you know just like me
you know realizing and pruning a tree
yeah well I mean in a way aren't our
lives like trees be raised and prune
in a sense in a metaphorical sense yeah
in a literal sense no I don't do bond
side do you know I would love to but I
just don't think I know what I'm doing
well I mean there's only one way to find
out right yeah yeah yeah how do you feel
about um how do you feel about Trump's
big revelation that the the bad old 75
year old guy that got pushed over was
actually like a super secret anti facin
yeah I'm gonna talk about that tomorrow
that guy so my show started in western
Massachusetts in a place called
Northampton and 10 minutes from
Northampton is Amherst Massachusetts and
these are like some of the most liberal
places in the country we're like 85 or
even 88 percent of the population will
vote for Democrats and presidential
elections that's where this guy is from
and just you know the idea it's I feel
like we've been desensitized where when
Trump tweets that the debate is whether
Trump's right rather than the insanity
of the fact that the president tweeted
something from Oh a n reported by some
Sputnik news guy who works for oen you
know that but that's the story not the
debate over the facts yeah whether or
not this Alex Jones piece or this
project Veritas piece or this o a n
piece is actually correct but why is
president tweeting out it's absolutely
insane and we did what did you make of
it
uh obviously I think it's absolutely
batshit insane did we ever figure out
what Obama Kate was that still uh
top-secret as well I'm still researching
that I I do think that maybe by like
October thirtieth we might hear
something a little more definitive about
it and we'll just just run out of time
being able to debunk it before the
election oh darn that's my prediction
mm-hmm what do you think about like the
the defund the police make AB and all
that stuff you have any thoughts on any
of this stuff I I do and I've put out a
bunch of clips about it and for the most
part people are not that furious with me
I mean listen I I don't believe that
defund the police makes any sense and I
don't believe abolish the police makes
any sense and if what you mean by that
is reform the police then I'm with you
but I would call it that like I wouldn't
defund the police if you actually mean
something different and so I gave like
my bullet list of
police should be demilitarized and
funding should be restricted so that
can't be used to buy these huge military
vehicles or RPGs training for police
should be two to three times as long and
in some countries it's much longer it
should include a lot of social work type
training so you actually learn to
de-escalate situations there's a
resource central database of bad police
actors so that police departments can't
act stupid when they hire someone and
then we learn like they had 18
complaints at their last job and the
police chief says we didn't know like
there should be a central bad actor
database that police departments have to
both report to and check if they're
going to hire somebody you know I have
this long list of stuff and the truth is
sometimes police departments are
underfunded there are some police
departments where they don't have enough
officers and so what they do is the
really cheap policing stuff of like
let's just send out our officers to the
poor areas which and actually
exacerbates the problem that we're
trying to fix so that that's what I take
on it
how do you feel about um oh shoot I just
I read something that just completely
side train my thought oh oh how do you
feel about the UM have you heard about
is it I think campaign zero like that
list of like eight to ten reforms or
whatever the police department should
take into account better like
data-driven reforms have you read into
that at all or I I bookmarked it but I
do I haven't read what the eight to ten
reforms are yet gotcha it's pretty
interesting I think it's got a lot of
good stuff there or anybody pays the
ones I mentioned yeah every single thing
you just mentioned is more or less
included there Oh looks like an broken
windows policing more specialized
training and like de-escalation training
for cops more strict use of force policy
so that we're not just shooting people
immediately you know like having
resources more appropriate allocated to
like mental health specialists rather
than just police officers being called
for every single issue yeah there's like
there's a lot of good stuff on there I
think yeah a lot people get mad if you
mention that but but why would why do
people get mad though it seems
reasonable
um yeah way maybe I'm oh man dude I'm so
stuck in this stupid like hole of like
irrelevant political thought so this
might not be like more mainstream but
like in my corner of the Internet
people are really mad anytime you
mentioned like reforming the police
because they just want to see it like
abolished or defunded or go over it yeah
I don't know how mainstream and American
thought that is right now I know that
the Minneapolis City Council I think so
that they pledged to quote unquote
abolish their police force although I'm
not sure what that means
have you read into the how Camden
reformed their police yeah I have yeah
and it's quite interesting yeah very
interesting a lot of people just say
Camden abolished their Police Department
and then they leave it at that but they
don't mention the fact that Camden
doubled the size of their County Police
Department you know gave it a lot more
funding but then changed the way they
approached policing and it seems to have
working out a bit better for them yeah
yeah I you know one of the things that I
did ten days ago and I haven't looked
back is I no longer look at the replies
feed on my Twitter so yeah I'll tweet
and then I'm walking through it right
now I'll go to my verified feed and I'll
look there which is like I I get that
you know it's like blue checkmark people
and and that I'm kind of creating an
echo chamber but the replies feed the
mentions feed is so toxic then I will
just look at the the posts from the
people I follow like I'm just not even
looking at the mentions feed because
it's such trash and it was actually
affecting me in a very negative way yeah
holy jeez it's insane yeah yeah I
remember you expressed your concern a
while ago that you were worried that the
types of responses you get to certain to
to certain things that you talk about
can dissuade you sometimes I'm talking
about those things yes so for instance
if you have even the slightest of
criticisms about like Bernie Sanders
were a or C you're gonna get a deli a
deluge of like negative come dailies
yeah of like horrible negative comments
that like mixes like it's not even worth
it for me to address these issues yeah
although I am past that and you know
what since since Bernie lost three super
Tuesday's in a row you know like the 5th
March 3rd 10th and 17th and I've been
sort of like issuing what I think are
pretty rational critiques of why he lost
people it's there's still some hate but
people seem much more willing to
actually hear reason on a lot of these
issues the last couple months anyway
yeah for sure
yeah yeah I think people live like like
I'm so glad be getting past the primary
[ __ ] like moving forward looking forward
to the general like it's just so clear
and the fact that like again I try to
preface this because my side of the unit
is so crazy politics on YouTube and
twitches it's just horrible and nobody
should be here nobody should have a
voice here it's just abysmal
but like this these there are so many
people on the left that are entertaining
online that are entertaining these ideas
that like maybe Trump would be better
than Biden because Biden you know voted
for the 94 crime bill like Judy's crazy
stupid opinions yeah someone called me
and said Biden supports cutting social
security in the 90s when he was asked
would you take it off the table he said
no I wouldn't
preemptively take it off the table like
he never actually proposed a cut and it
was almost 30 years ago like wow that's
not relevant to look at what Trump was
saying 30 years ago you know it's not
relevant to what's going on right now
yeah 20 years ago wasn't Trump saying if
he was gonna run he'd run as a
Republican because they're stupid and
easily gullible you know that that was a
widely disseminated fake quote oh is
that a fake quote it's very it's it's
like it's weaponized fake gotcha yeah
it's agressive fake me all right dude
listen I gotta go but I want to play in
this chess tournament with you on
Tuesday it's in your calendar so I hope
to see you there and by the way a
shout-out to your subreddit your
subreddit seems to actually like me it's
one of the very few subreddits that
likes me most subreddits hate me yeah my
separate it seems to like everybody in
there they get around a lot so yep
likewise we'll talk to you soon okay